1 oggi parliamo di smart systems
sistemi intelligenti
importanti nella società delle
comunicazioni alla quale viviamo sempre
di più importante domani e dopodomani
cos'è uno smart system in generale uno
smart sisma o gli smarties team al
plurale sono dei sistemi praticamente
che danno
intelligenze che sono connessi tra di
loro e connesse con il mondo esterno e
hanno la possibilità di catturare
energia e dall'ambiente esterno per
autoalimentarsi di trasmettere dati di
processare questi dati quindi la
definizione di smart system è una
definizione dinamica perché quello che
intelligente voi ci sarà meno
intelligente domani ma in generale
questi concetti di sistemi che possono
essere alimentati trovando l'energia sul
posto dove si trovano e riescono a
processare i dati prendere decisioni e
prevedere azioni future è un concetto
valido anche se sempre più da potenziale
nel futuro perché gli smart sistema
system sono importanti perché in un
mondo che comunica sempre a livello
globale
sono tutti in un mondo dei social
network da facebook
linkedin twitter dove le comunicazioni
arrivano in tempo reale dove c'è la
possibilità del singolo di raggiungere
milione di altri individui tutto questo
viaggio su basi tecnologiche nuove sono
sensori di vario tipo che riescono a
trasmettere l'importanza l'informazione
a elaborarla ea renderla fruibile a
tutti quanti sono ovviamente gli
elementi essenziali e diciamo che queste
smart system ritroviamo nella in maniera
pervasiva nella vita di tutti i giorni
dalla che si chiama guerra ball l'ex
dell'elettronica che si indossa gli
abiti sempre di più dai militari sul
campo di battaglia
alle persone che vogliono che fanno
fitness avranno sempre di più sensore su
sulle braccia per catturare diciamo
la frequenza delle cardiache per
iniettare l'insulina con delle nano
pompe oppure per esempio per monitorare
i sistemi quali il cane qui ne abbiamo
uno bello grosso o per monitorare
slavine
dappertutto ci sono questi sistemi che
prendono azione sulla base di quello che
vedono li trasmettono e devono essere
autosufficienti per poter ge trasmettere
l'energia quindi non ci possono metterla
non c'è l'arredamento della su lucano le
batterie non possa essere sufficiente
sia le batterie ci vogliono per fare lo
storage di energia immagazzina l'energia
ma poi se la devono catturare per avere
degli spunti al momento giusto e come se
la caturano con quella che si chiama
diciamo poi puoi essere la differenza di
pressione può essere a differenza di
energia
diciamo potere dei lidi di
temperatura tra due punti in tantissime
in maniera c'e la possibilita di fare
questo harvesting prendere sul posto
dell'energia allora questi sistemi vanno
avanti in questa maniera e in un mondo
interconnesso sono sempre più importanti
per dargli un esempio nel 2020 ci
saranno 50 miliardi di unità
di unità connesse e nel mondo quindi
volumi enormi che vanno dalle auto che
si guidano da sole i sistemi radar
alla wearable elettronics al medicare
dappertutto troveremo alla robotica
dappertutto ci saranno queste se hai
google glasses di oggi
allora vediamo un pochino chi sono gli
attori in gioco e ovviamente per poter
fare questi i concetti che sta
esprimendo intanto sono universale
quindi valgono in qualsiasi zona del
pianeta dopo di che vedremo di calarla
nella realtà locale perché alla fine o
di scudi formico se c'è il buono per me
in queste cose insomma parliamo di cose
che interessano la luna o interesso
anche il territorio locale vedrete che
molte di queste cose interessano il
territorio locale per linguaggio
universale e questo è una conseguenza
della società delle comunicazioni oggi
quello che sembrava impossibile in un
mostro di un posto perché non c'erano le
infrastrutture perché non c'erano di
sapere grazie a questa internet che ti
permette di collegarti con tutto il
mondo che rende fruibile o accessibile
sia il mondo del capitolo praticamente
classi capitale
basta sapere a trovare attraverso google
chi si occupa di queste cose ovviamente
dietro ci deve essere l'idea di fondo è
capace di allertare il capitalista di
turno ci devono essere la capacità di
sviluppare software perché questi questi
smart system sono una parte composta da
hardware quindi connessione dei fili
circuiti elettronici ma c'è una parte
dell'intelligente di software embedded
che devono essere le università i centri
di ricerca anche se disperse nel mondo
non per forza congiunta in un singolo
mondo che devono essere anche le
capacita manifatturiere per poter fare
queste cose anche queste possono essere
disperse un pezzo di operazione si fa un
post è un altro paese un altro posto e
ci deve essere soprattutto un ambiente
perdere per l'innovazione non ci devono
essere barriere all'innovazione questo è
il fatto essenziale la è la chiave di
tutto vediamo quali sono questi basic
ingredienti proprio gli ingredienti di
base per fare questa bella pizza che si
chiama smart sist
allora prima di tutto la cosa di gran
lunga la più importante l'idea vincente
ci deve essere l'idea che porta al
brevetto che porta a fare un oggetto
nuovo a uno smart sistema di un nuovo
tipo senza di questo non si va da
nessuna parte e ovviamente
queste idee a volte
possono portare a scontrarsi con dei
paradigmi che la realtà comune di non si
può fare non abbiamo i soldi e
l'ambiente si ostacola come facciamo
quindi
le cose vincenti quelle che
rivoluzionano il mondo sono quelle che
vanno al di là dei paradigmi quindi che
riescono a superare il blocco della
normalità e ovviamente ci vuole anche un
tempo di esecuzione
le case chiuse un time nessuna cosa è
vera per per l'eternità tu pensa una
cosa la fai in tempo utile la dai al
mercato internet ti permette di
usufruire del mondo intero però se ci
metti 16 anni un altro lo fa in tre mesi
si è tagliato fuori quindi questo è
importante poi c'è lo spirito
imprenditoriale di avere le idee chiare
queste sono importanti e ci deve essere
anche la capacità di prendere due
rischio non c'è nessuna idea vincente
che si possa essere portate avanti col
rischio zero queste cose avvengono nel
un ambiente diciamo di persone
comodamente
sprofondato in un sofà che non sono
legate all'innovazione che non portano
niente di nuovo al mondo
ovviamente ci devono essere siccome il
sapere non è tutto concentrato in un
punto non essere le capacità di fare
networking di collegarsi con le buone
università per potersi appropriare degli
ip intellectual property necessarie e
così via e ancora una volta la società
delle comunicazione agevola questa
capacità di fare al networking 20 anni
fa 1 non parlava l'inglese e niente da
tagliato fuori adesso
volendo senza spostarsi da andrea
d'inghilterra ha deciso di prendermi nel
centro californiano è che vai a seguire
tanto di quei film se sei intelligente
leahy voglioso tutti i giorni ore per
ore per ora di film che parla in inglese
con al centro californiano insomma
teoricamente è possibile senza spostarsi
dalla sedia immaginare vent'anni fa non
cento anni fa tutto questo è impossibile
bisognava andare in inghilterra che si
recava lì poi si beccavano comunità
degli italiani siano spese di soldi per
niente anche questo succedeva poi il
fondo resi come dicevo prima il
fundraising non è impossibile basta
avere il network i giusti è l'idea
vincente di base e l'idea poi le persone
che hanno soldi riescono a capire
sniffano dicevamo il dott il bene e dopo
di che ci vuole anche la education nel
senso di istruzione all'inglese quindi
la capacità di avere il background
giusto perché porta alla fertilità
dell'ire se uno è ignorante ragazzi e
può fare delle altre cose però non può
andare nell'ambiente degli smart system
e ovviamente l'ambiente locale queste
cose le offre e poi ci vuole il giusto
mindset uno che decide di fare siamo è
il tipo di mestiere che possa essere il
gelataio il panettiere un'altra cosa fa
delle cose utilissima alla società belle
anche possono anche essere innovativo ma
non c'entro con l'ambiente degli smart
esiste ci vuole un ambiente una mente
proiettata all'innovazione al futuro a
fare cose nuove sempre radicali è la
parola giusta è innovazione radicale
cioè dire che rompe gli schemi che va al
di là delle cose note cosa offre il
territorio ecco questo dicevo quindi è
un linguaggio universale
e per tutti quanti al mondo
se ci sono quelle quelle famose
ingredienti della education rischi take
l'idea vincente così via ma veniamo
caliamo nella realtà locale a mio
giudizio il capital fund anche se non
c'è localmente lo si può procacciare
attraverso diciamo internet avendo il
network gerseb le buone università
esistono e ci sono le buone università
non si spende tanto ci sono delle punte
di eccellenza oggi siamo in una di
queste e si può fare si può lavorare
le start up sono limitate sul caro dr
non ce ne sono tante perché il mindset
verso l'innovazione non è molto evidente
però occorre fare il primo passo
senza di queste questo piccolo discorso
di oggi è soprattutto legato alle start
up a quelli quei giovani che vogliono
fare qualcosa di radicale e hanno voglia
di scommettersi e di rischiare se hanno
delle idee brillanti in testa
il software questo esiste di più perché
il pozzo ne sa aggregate di pochi
ingegneri pochi per i di degli
informatici insieme che messe insieme
dei suoi a sviluppare software vedete a
quante di quelle application le app
famose per l'ambiente di apple sono nate
nel mondo tanto vengono anche da questo
modo però quello che un ambiente molto
molto più diciamo soft e
changeable che proprio modificarsi
radicalmente
qui parliamo di negli smart system
siccome c'è la presenza il connubio di
hardware software queste cose diciamo
sono molto più radicale è forte se una
delle idee vincenti durano di più nel
tempo
il manufatto o messo una linea gialla
vedi un semaforo giallo e ci sono delle
realtà ma non c'è tantissimo
quindi in generale il giudizio sul
territorio e medio ci sono delle cose
belle come l'istruzione delle altre cose
che si possono trovare come il capitale
delle altre cose che mancano e
soprattutto manca la voglia di fare le
cose che è quella che può rompere tutte
queste barriere questi paradigmi e che
permette di andare avanti
alla fine io ho concluderei quello che
mi dicendo che tutto si può rimuovere se
ci sono le idee e la capacità di fare di
prendere il rischio e alla fine il
limite e l'innovazione stessa e la
capacità di andare avanti con
l'immaginazione e la voglia di uscire da
solo